- [Voiceover] So I've said that
if you have a vector field,
a two-dimensional vector field
with component functions P and Q,
that the divergence of this
guy, the divergence of v,
which is a scalar-valued
function of x and y,
is by definition, the
partial derivative of P,
with respect to x, plus the
partial derivative of Q,
with respect to y.
And there's actually another
notation for divergence
that's kind of helpful for
remembering the formula.
And what it is, is you
take this nabla symbol,
that upside down triangle that
we also use for the gradient,
and imagine taking the
dot product between that
and your vector-valued function.
And as we did with the gradient,
the loose mnemonic you have
for this upside down triangle,
as you think of it as a vector,
full of partial differential operators,
and that sounds fancy but all it means
is you kind of take
this partial, partial x,
a thing that wants to take in a function
and take its partial derivative,
and that's its first component,
and the second component
is this partial, partial y,
a thing that wants to take in a function
and take its partial
derivative with respect to y.
And, you know, loosely
this isn't really a vector,
these aren't numbers, or
functions, or things like that,
but it's something you can write down
and it'll be kind of helpful symbolically.
And you imagine taking
the dot product with that,
and, you know, v who has components,
these scalar-valued functions,
P of xy, and Q of xy.
And when you imagine
doing this dot product,
and you're kind of lining up terms
and the first one multiplied
by the second, right,
quote unquote multiplied,
because, in this case,
when I say this first
component multiplied by p,
I really mean you're taking
that partial derivative operator
partial, partial x,
and evaluating it at p.
That's kind of what multiplication
looks like in this case.
So, you take that, and as per
the dot product you then add,
what happens if you take
this partial operator,
this partial, partial
y, and quote unquote,
multiply it with q.
Which, in the case of an operator,
means you kind of give it the function q
and it's gonna take
its partial derivative.
So, we see we get the
same thing over here,
it's the same formula that we have,
and it's just kind of a nice, little,
you can think of it as a mnemonic device
for remembering what the divergence is.
But another nice thing, this can apply
to higher-dimensional functions, as well.
Right? If we have
something that, let's see,
something that's a vector-valued function,
and it's gonna be a
three-dimensional vector field.
So, it's got x, y, and z as its inputs,
and its output then also has
to have three dimensions.
So, it might be like, P, Q, and R,
and all of these are functions of x and y.
So, that's P of x and y, Q,
oh no, x, y, and z, right?
So, P of x, y, kind of got in the habit
of two dimensions there, P of
x, y and z, Q of x, y, and z,
and then R of x, y, and z.
And I haven't talked about
three-dimensional divergence.
But if you think of this
and then you imagine
doing your nabla, dotted
with the vector-valued function,
it can still make sense.
And in this case, that
nabla you're thinking of
as having three different components.
It's gonna be, on the one
hand this partial, partial x,
I should say partial x there, partial x,
now the second component
is partial, partial y,
and the last component
is partial, partial z.
And the ordering of
these, of the variables,
here, x, y and z is just
whatever I have here.
So, even if they didn't
have the names x, y, z,
you kinda out them in the same order
that they show up in your function.
And when you imagine taking
the dot product between this,
and your P as a function, Q as a function,
and R as a function, vector-valued output,
what you get, and I'll write it over here,
you take that partial, partial
x and kind of multiply it,
with P, which means you're
really evaluating at P.
So, partial x here.
Then you add partial, partial y.
And you're evaluating at Q,
because you're kind of imagining
multiplying these second components.
And you'll add what happens
when you multiply by
these third components,
or that's partial, partial
z, by that last component.
And, you know, since I haven't talked
about three-dimensional vector fields,
with three-dimensional
divergence, this last term,
maybe it's not given that you'd
have as strong an intuition
for why this shows up in
divergence as the other two,
but it's actually quite similar,
you're thinking about changes
to the z component of a vector
as the value z, of the input,
as you're kind of moving up
and down and that direction changes.
But this pattern will go
for even higher dimensions
that we can't visualize, four,
five, 100, whatever you want.
And that's what makes this
notation here quite nice,
is that it encapsulates that
and gives a really compact way
of describing this formula that,
it has a simple pattern to it,
but would otherwise kind of
get out of hand to write.
See you next video.